[Music]
How is Cristian Cásseres greeting you with
his new newscast in
Spanish in Las Vegas? He is preparing to
offer
$1,500 for trips from left
completely free of charge in OSAs Acción with
the Zero Fatalities Coalition over
the weekend.  you can get a
ten dollar discount for a trip
with left with the code right smart ld w
and if you plan to go to the lake look this
weekend leave the water toys at home
some items like floats
beach balls float sticks are now
prohibited in  this area officials
said these give people a
false belief of safety as they have
seen cases of drowning and first
frayre is back
this month's focus will be sustainability the company
try boulet will be there with a
commitment to use 100%  of
renewable energy in less than a decade it also
plans to plant 5 million trees in
the next five years you will also be able to
enjoy handicrafts among
Live entertainment and you can even get
your kobe 19 shot and we will have
temperatures in the 90s to
start the weekend however
we will be back in the heat and we will see
temperatures exceeding 100 degrees
for the weekend I am cristian
cásseres with your informative award  from
news now in Spanish good day
[Music]